in your view how important is it for the
director
to be a leader on set and if so
what are some of the verbal cues
nonverbal cues that they are the leader
how do you feel like you can trust them
to be led well that
that's a really good question that i've
never really
sat and thought about before i i think
it's important for there
to be somebody in charge on the set
because
you know there are actors or strange
creatures they have egos and
and opinions and i remember one movie
that i shot
a few years ago
where the director and the star
were constantly fighting
publicly in front of the rest of the
cast screaming at each other
i want you to do it this way no i'm not
going to do it this way that's
i i'm not going to play the
character this way
and i mean it made the rest of us
i mean we were you know just waiting to
shoot something and they would be having
these
screaming arguments with each other in
front of everybody
and it sort of makes you feel
uncomfortable
and and takes away your focus from what
you're
you're there to concentrate on and
delivering the kind of performance you
want to a real authentic performance
if it was not a happy
set
and i
i will say that in this case i believe
that the actor
who had the problem shouldn't have
signed on to the project
beca this is not the first time i i'm
guessing that
that he uh was made aware of how the
director wanted him to play this role
i mean don't sign on to a project if
you're if you and the director aren't on
the same page and have the same
general vision i don't think i don't
know where this came from but it was a
very uncomfortable experience and
and yes i think there there has to be a
leader and the director is the guy that
uh
that does that i in in my opinion
i've also been on shoots where
things were sort of chaotic and maybe
morale wasn't the best and
another actor stepped up and sort of
brought the cast together and
and uh gave him a pep talk and you know
let's get through this thing we can do
this
um it may not be gone with the wind but
uh we're gonna you know hold our heads
high and
give the best performances we can and
walk out of here feeling good about what
we did
and that's happened a couple of times
too where the director
really wasn't the one in charge and
things were rapidly falling apart
but another actor stepped up and and
pulled it together
so yes i do think that it's important
that there be a chain of command
and somebody at the top to make
decisions
and rally the troops and
motivate people and inspire people
and give
especially the actors a pla and i hate
this word sometimes
it sounds so warm and fuzzy give them a
safe place to do what actors do
um that's important that's important and
some directors just won't let actors be
actors they won't let them do what they
do
they want a particular
some directors are technical directors
they know what they want technically but
they
they're not the best at communicating
to actors in in a language that actors
can understand
and then translate into a performance
other actors are actors direct or other
directors are actors directors who
can speak that language and and um
and aren't afraid to let the actors do
what they do
and take those risks and and maybe try
things that
are a little bit off the beaten path and
uh
and experiment so that's what gives the
feeling of a safe set
in some ways you think when when that
director is just more willing to
give leeway it's not so based on the
script and and
there's just more room for sort of
trying things differently i
i like that environment i i i kind of
prefer that
um it's a it's a
symbiotic relationship and there's a lot
of trust involved the director has to
trust the actors that they know what to
do and the actors have to trust the
vision of the director as well
most of the time it's a very happy
collaboration
but sometimes it derails a little bit
one way or the other but
most of the time gets back on track
again usually it works out well
sure well anytime you're dealing with a
large group of people there's sort of a
mob mentality
you know yeah and and and one bad thing
could send it one way or the other
and so how have you seen an actor or
excuse me
a director steer the ship back let's
suppose some things happen
weather issues whatever technical
problems and the morale is bad it's late
at night
without naming names have you have you
seen somebody steer it
in the right course and or maybe just by
saying it's a wrap for the day
just away from the the rocks that we're
imminently going to crash into
yeah and turn the project into a
disaster no i've never
been on one of those okay luckily no i
never have
um some days are
not as good as others and i think you're
right
you have to make a decision to just wrap
for the day
let everybody go have a cocktail or have
a good dinner or a great night's sleep
and
and tomorrow's another day you know
and i've i've seen i've seen things turn
around after a good night's sleep
yeah that were that we're headed for
imminent disaster before
the director called let's wrap for the
day
you